ركوب الأمواج في بوروروكا أمر خطير للغاية
أي خطأ يمكن أن يكلفك حياتك
لكنه شعور جيد أنه عندما
نحن في الموجة التي نسيناها
كل اسمي سيرجيو لاوس أنا راكب أمواج
متخصص في ظاهرة
بوروروكا مع رقمين قياسيين عالميين
تصفح أطول موجة في العالم في
amazônia pororoca هو الاسم الذي يطلق على
أخطر ظاهرة في البرازيل هي 1
مليون متر مكعب من المياه التي
تم التقدم من المحيط إلى
النهر يسافر لمسافات لا يمكن تصورها
يمكننا ركوب الأمواج والأمواج أكثر
الأطول في العالم
موجة بوروروكا تمامًا
تختلف عن المحيط في المحيط نحن
يتصفح في البحر بالمياه المالحة
لذلك نحن نطفو أكثر
في النهر لدينا مياه عذبة أكثر
كثيفة لذلك لا يمكننا الحصول عليها
الكثير من التقلبات موجة من البوروروكا هي
يمكن أن تختلف كثيرا عن حجمها
يمكن أن يكون لدينا موجات نصف متر أو
موجات تصل إلى أربعة أمتار في المرحلة
الأمواج قوية جدا وتأتي معها
فيضان المياه لدينا الكثير
جذوع باولو جامبوس في منتصف الطريق
ركوب الأمواج في بوروروكا شيء سامي حيث
يمكننا محاولة الاتصال كثيرًا
حميم مع الطبيعة
لأننا في أكبر منطقة حيوية في
كوكب وتصفح الأزياء التي عمليا
ليس له نهاية
لا يوصف
[أغنية]